[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
oh no hey it's joe hello everybody happy
friday
welcome
welcome to friday congrats sailor you've
made it to friday
uh as they say on the internet um hey
i'm john luke welcome to gamespot we're
gonna be hanging out this friday
with a little game called persona 4
arena ultimax
uh otherwise known as the ultra what the
ultimax ultra suplex hold
yeah in japanese which is uh
fantastic i
really wish they stuck with that name
here i am joined by
the wonderful evan langer
howdy gamers i'm wearing a yellow today
in honor of the investigation team
uh is that monkey ball actually is that
weird yeah this is my monkey okay so
sega
yeah so
yes on brand yes um
i thought about wearing my yellow chia
shirt but it was it was in the wash so i
could not wear it
i'm also joined by ben janka
hello there i'm
just wearing
whatever shirt i had on today
i didn't mean to start a whole shirt
thing i'm sorry
no no it's all good
and uh yeah
it's just a casual stream we're gonna
just be hanging out playing some persona
for arena uh this is like my favorite
fighting game probably of all time uh
not just because it's persona only the
only fifty percent maybe a good sixty
percent because it's personal
but uh i don't know i i i genuinely love
this game i think it's a really good
fighting game in a um
a great persona game so yeah we're gonna
get into it um
uh ben you have a lobby set up right
yeah i made a lobby uh you've got an
invite waiting for you and i said
are we are we opening this up for anyone
who wants to jump in is that how we're
doing
because i've got i've got that room it
is it is wide open oh yeah do we wanna
i gotta create a p card please come and
fight us you know fight your friends
just like in the game
it'll be it'll be a great time
uh i've been having a good time shaking
off the rust also this is a version of
the game we never got so there's a whole
bunch of stuff that just
doesn't doesn't work if you played a
whole bunch of the other console ones
yeah this is based on the arcade uh
patch
i'm pretty sure the shadows are busted
um even more so than they currently were
uh remind me is this the kind of game
where i have to pick my character in
advance did you actually get a character
i actually have a character select
screen i
so prefer that um
uh is there
is oh so the room is just up there so
who can join if they want okay just fun
find my name in player match and i i
think you should be able to join okay
and i should be able to just
uh get ready myself so let's do this
oh let's go first match
all right let's see who's in the ring
all right
if you're going jean pay i gotta go my
girl yeah you gotta start off with with
what's in your heart first and then you
can kind of meander
what are their uh what are their like
dumb names they gave them for this game
uh like i know ga is like the carnivore
who discarded womanhood yup i don't know
june pays
i think he's like the the
the mess up
slugger or something
all right well
it's a mess up slugger versus the
carnivore who decided womanhood let's
go it's cheat it's ga satsunaka saturday
according to mark stanley
every saturday
all of them
saw tanaka saturday
i can't believe we put michael hyman's
character in this game from final
fantasy 14 online i know that's crazy
that's wild
let's play fair and square
oh you're playing you're playing
oh yeah yeah
i don't know how to commentate fighting
games but i'll do it they're dupe
they're kicking and fighting
um
let's see let's see chad uh in the
twitch chat
uh is this a fighting game or something
like persona 5 royal this is a fighting
game with the characters of not only
persona 4 but also persona 3. um if your
persona 4 golden is like the persona 5
royal equivalent of persona 4. but this
is also a sequel to persona 3 and 4 so
if you want to play story mode don't
let's you play persona 3 and 4.
um
let's see
uh
i've been uh i've been practicing i've
been practicing yeah i'm like i played a
little bit yesterday to kind of warm up
and i was doing all right but it's
definitely like
i vaguely remember chia's combos and so
it's
i think that's hurting me more than it's
helping because i'm trying to like be
like how do i do that thing
so there's also because i've been
playing a lot of blazblue again recently
because uh it's it's netcode update
and the thing that's really messed me up
i've realized is how much i played uh
what is it
the crosstalk game oh yeah yeah because
i just think that the characters play
like like they do a crosstag
so it's it's a it's a weird thing to
kind of get used to also it's worth
mentioning this game doesn't have its
rollback netcode yet yeah yeah we're
getting we're getting some stutter here
i uh i tried playing a little bit last
night too to train and i was like i'm
not really shocked like how few people
were playing this game like two weeks
later and i was like oh
um yeah
i got some
if you are down to play you know we're
totally open to that we have a lot we
have a lobby going uh once this uh once
this is over we will uh you'll see the
lobby name and you are more than welcome
to join in uh we are also playing the
ps4 version so if you're playing the ps4
version please feel free to join in
um
yeah anyways
i don't need to interrupt your
conversation oh you're good you're good
someone made a hilarious
june pay ace defect or stupay ace
defective joke
it's important
it's what he
i think i know exactly what you're
talking about you probably know what i'm
talking about
i can't say it
i love it um
cool so if you're in the chat and if you
want to play there's the room name right
there we got someone in here uh
uh this person i don't know how to say
your name i apologize
um and if you want in
join the room
come fight us
um say some funny things in the little
chat bubbles like uh
a serious duel to the death that's
lighthearted and fun
um
yeah uh
why is this your favorite fighting game
ask someone in the chat
uh well so it's my favorite fighting
game because i mean i got into it
because of persona obviously um with
sort of like hey wow like um
a fighting game based off some of my
favorite characters of all time that's
awesome um
but then i actually have found it find
it to be a very accessible fighting game
it's only a four button fighter and one
of the buttons has um a auto combo
system it was i think it was the first
uh
arc system games to introduce the idea
of an auto combo
and it's actually it works really well
because i think it just like makes the
game very easy to get into but then on
top of that the game does have a lot of
depth so i think it's just it's one of
those games that like i'm not gonna
claim it's like the greatest fighting
game but i think it's just for me
personally it like
holds a lot of love in my heart for it
because of uh you know
respect and reference it does to the
source material mixed with just like
it's also a really damn good fighter
that's some interesting stuff with the
persona mechanics and all that
i promise to play characters that aren't
just to freak out
no it's fine i am not good at this game
at all
i'm just here to have fun with my girl
yukiko
[Music]
so i think i think this is the year i'm
gonna actually play personal four
oh that's right you've never played it
all the way through have you yeah i'm uh
i'm gonna start it up when i get my
steam deck and i'm gonna play the pc
version on it well that's a good idea
it was intended on the portable console
it'll feel like it's 60 fps and
look really nice
that kind of thing
yeah which makes me feel sorry because
i've rebounded my
uh vita copy that i thought i lost a
long time ago
wait a minute the steam deck you know
played in in crisp hd
yeah
see all those 2008 models
yeah
the game actually looks great on pc
that's not a oh yeah it's not as big or
anything looks really good on pc
yeah and the uh
difficulty customization is super cool
yes that was really helpful to like not
have to grind to beat the game yeah
yeah like genuinely like
uh
i think that games combat is super
rewarding but also like if you just
don't want to engage with it you don't
have to and that's awesome
yeah
gg good game i had fun
hell yeah i'm more than happy to get
stomped on by
mitsuhu that's me
right there with it awesome
all right who's going to be ben streak
i do have it set up if if a streak
happens for too long it'll
it'll force the person out so we get
more okay do i want to save this replay
no
let's see
it's ben versus ethereal who's gonna win
is this person going to kick your ass
man
who are they going with no i'm gonna mix
it up i'm gonna i'm gonna do some real
just dedicate this one to michael
[Laughter]
so this one's for him
wherever he is hopefully sleeping
yeah
so they picked away that's real in the
chat everyone starts off somewhere if
you were good to start off with that'd
be no fun you're absolutely right now
i'm going to root for you against ben no
offense
please please do
uh
i'm one of those people who likes
getting my ass kicked and fighting games
because i feel like i learned the most
then
uh that's a good viewpoint
yeah sorry for making you wait give me
give me something to try for and be
better at
you also just picked the most cursed
teddy
uh yeah that is an interesting color
you got it you gotta have the the eyes
you gotta have the
like weird fresh color outfit
it's uh it's really important
somebody have like a joker skin in this
one i don't mean
[Music]
spoilers for persona 4 by the way
well that character is a playable
fighter in the game yeah but that's what
i'm saying like oh that kind of is also
a spoiler yeah it is well that's what i
was saying like if you want to play the
story mode of this game like just don't
unless you play persona 3 m4 oh oh
you also have like no context it very
much assumes you already know and love
these characters it would yeah i can't
imagine trying to play this
with no context and having a good time
uh
when we get in a p5 fighting game hey
you never know maybe they were tinkering
with this when they were making p5 and
they're like oh let's just re-release p4
yeah
i would really really like one um
i mean can you imagine it in the like i
love this 2d art like this is like peak
2d sprite here but can you also imagine
it
uh i would love that so much i just want
everything in the guilty gear
see what i really love about this game
and i didn't even know until they
announced the remaster is that like the
persona 3 characters are aged up because
this takes place like canonically a few
years later so if they do p5 fighting i
want to see the persona 4 characters
aged up now if they do that
i would worry that all of three four and
five would be too many characters maybe
so if we have the compromise in the aged
p4
a lot
should put money on that um
great job ethereal thank you for joining
us too and feel free to stay in the
lobby if you'd like yeah please do
yeah if anyone's playing elizabeth
online you know they're uh
you know they're good
i heard margaret was really good in like
the original not the 2.0 version um
oh did they did they nerf her
i think they know yeah more people
scrolling up you're gonna have to see it
hell yeah
all right john luke
i guess
let me let me think who do i want to
pick
go with the character nobody would
expect
i i absolutely hated canon 3 i thought
he was so annoying um but i actually
really like him in this game
he's eight he's aged up in this one and
he's matured and and it's it's good he's
got cold hardwood yeah i was gonna say
shout out to coramara
someone cared
[Music]
let's see
this is like picking the character isn't
even the thing it's actually getting the
right music yeah that's the important
part
and there there's just so many so many
tracks
yeah there's because it's like so
there's all the three and spin-offs and
ford and all this stuff and then all the
tracks for this game which they have
like one for each character and
it's like yeah
uh that's actually one of my biggest
disappointments with persona 5 dancing
of all things is they made it too early
it's like where's the royal music and
the strikers music and the q2 music and
all this good yeah music
i think the
five dancing actually has the weakest uh
trackers of all the dancing games
apparently uh shadow cannon just turned
into little kenneth
oh is it oh huh you don't know that
i haven't like because i'm still playing
through arena story i'm trying not to
touch the ultimake stuff as much so like
i don't know a lot about yukari and june
pay and canada in this game yet
or the new guy uh with the red hair i
don't know
such a great addition
such a great addition to the cast
i like the i like i like lapras a lot
though
libraries were genuinely fantastic okay
cool i was gonna say
they know how they do know how to make
new interesting characters i mean
strikers
yo
so here's the deal if you want a good
spin-off character they have to be a
robot of some variety yeah pretty much
yes
yes
brooklyn accent
that's my accent
i love it though
yeah that was good that was a good fight
that was a really fun fight to watch
yeah
well
you may done able to give me an answer
or so i had thought ah
i get that reference
uneven funny reference
that's an answer
uh
also uh without getting too into
spoilers but um
this game sets up some stuff with
elizabeth that was really exciting to me
like i was like ooh that sounds cool
like i would like to see where that goes
and they have not done anything with
that setup here all right uh i'ma let
you guys decide who should i play as oh
shoot take a pic i'm not good with like
any character but yukiko so take your
pick
um
we're talking about libraries being cool
dude
uh gonna go oh god what music should i
do
like the fire up in the night wait
there's two versions of light to fire up
in the night yes because there's
a dark hour version and there's a
midnight channel version
it's the talk
okay dark hour one okay we're going dark
all right i'm about to get my ass beat
but ethereal i like you a lot so i'm
gonna let you kick my ass no problem
look they brought out their yukari
though
that's true
pink feather woman
uh i'm really sad that i never knew this
song existed until like
maybe a year ago
uh it's very good though mm-hmm it is
very good this one right i'm pretty sure
no i think it we it's from q right a
battle theme from killa thing
oh this is the battlefield you're right
i just like i think
i just like in dancing when akihiko is
just like slamming his fists against the
screen like dancing to it yeah um ben
have you not played q
you should play q
so i i want to but i want to get that
four before i head into it
you should you should play four players
but yeah after that you should play q
because q
is
uh
just pure fan service
for three or four characters in like the
best way it's so good
it's like um
like banger
i actually i went backwards i did q2
first because i was more interested in
the p5
that makes sense
i found out that they weren't like
connected connected like you play one
for the other so i was like i did q2
first
yeah
yeah also like uh
q1 it does an interesting thing where
you pick which um
which which is like which cast you focus
on so whether you start with the three
cast of the forecast and that actually
does change um a fair amount of the
dialogue throughout the game
it does actually have some solid replay
value
uh doing both routes
i imagine
for certain three people
yeah that's actually i went with the
three cast when i did it
and i really enjoyed um their route
quite a bit
i loved
we all talk about
all the time about hey man like when's
when
three remakes come in give us give us
that definitive persona 3. i think you
could genuinely
[Music]
take the idea of tartarus and like
reimagine it and make it like really
interesting here's what i want with
tartarus
make koi tecmo do the persona 3 remake
and have striker's combat in tartarus so
you can do that kind of like muso slash
like jerry genius that's what i want
with targets because there's 250
something floors like no wonder she's
what i gave up i almost gave up on
persona 3 so many times because of
tartarus it's a lot of grinding it's a
lot i think you could just like re-do it
and reduce the floors and change up the
the um
how much like xp you're getting and also
maybe actually make the floors
you know proper floors and not just
randomized
so i i'm bad at math and
calculus scares me even as a word
let's
see oh yeah
you know it's funny when i was in high
school i did really really well in
statistics and really really poorly in
calculus like my brain for some reason
just
statistics made way more sense in my
brain so if you're struggling don't beat
yourself up for me that was just what i
excelled on personally
um but thank you for listening to us
ramble about uh persona 3 remake and how
much
hey homie say tartarus while doing
homework
um but yeah i mean yeah persona 3 is
such an interesting case because yeah
like tartarus like even if they remade
it i don't know if i could still deal
with targaryens but it's also like the
story is
incredible in and of itself so it's like
it is
what do you do there yeah and i also
love
uh femzy and i'm also disappointed they
never did that with four and five
although i understand that's like
writing a whole another game so like
that's a lot of work um
those social links are genuinely like
some of the best social links i've ever
written
yeah it's it's funny like
because like with persona 3 like when
june paige comes up to in the beginning
it's just like he's just trying to be
friendly he does the exact same thing in
portable but everybody assumes he's
hitting on you i'm like that's such an
interesting dynamic change yeah
um
[Music]
he's also the one character you can't
romance in that game
with good reason yeah
which character
oh
if you can try to play it later
he's got he's got his eyes elsewhere
that's true
um
this is an interesting matchup adachi
versus reset i like it because resa is
not a she wasn't playable in the first
arena right she was at it
yeah
no no no she was she was only added in
in the second one
and and again i'm not gonna spoil these
for evan but like they have to like do
some interesting character stuff with
her to make that work um
in a way that i'm like oh rose a
microphone
yes exactly
well yeah cause like i i know in like
arena's story there's a reason why she's
not part of like the grand prix
but yeah but like ultimax uh i have not
seen that yet but i'm sure they're yeah
there is a reason
same with i guess margaret or margaret's
at his dlc i don't know if she's in the
story of ultimate uh i think she shows
up in the story but i
don't know
[Music]
all right well margaret's in the people
arena story she like talks to you in the
velvet room but can't like play with her
like elizabeth
the adachi stuff is interesting because
he actually gets his own like mini
campaign
yeah i i like read about that because
you have to like because it was dlc but
now it's like the thing you unlock after
yeah yeah getting through the story yeah
it was like
they changed all that it just naturally
unlocks that stuff
yeah because like i was confused at
first because i guess p4a's story was
added as dlc in the original ultimax but
they didn't change the menu for this
remaster so even though p4a comes first
it's at the bottom of the list
yeah yeah yeah
bottom of the list but it still is like
yeah you should play it first yeah it's
a little weird um
congrats
your abilities are clear
one i don't know i remember who was
playing hello
well you got this ben
it's a loss for everyone
[Music]
all right
all right ben you and me let's see
are you going to play as i'll play as
like the character that makes sense to
fight your character oh shoot we'll do
we'll do cannon fights uh yeah let's do
a canonical fight here okay
i should go with someone from four so i
can i can get like a preview here
uh okay
well you know what i'll do i'll do a
kaji who makes sense to fight fight
kanji i want to say naoto am i right on
that
uh i would say naoto or in a more
antagonistic way yosuke
like yes you're right about yes no
i know i don't know
all all you want is you just want kanji
to beat the [ __ ] out of yosuke
yeah
but you never just cannot make sense
because kanji is too nice of a guy he
wouldn't do it
yeah
josuke's got his hang-ups
[Music]
i think this is still uh troy baker
kanji as well right
yeah i think it was was it ultimax or
dancing when they were placed in there
thank
yeah i'm pretty sure he's still in
golden and then i think he's still in
arena as well
he is in arena because i hear his voice
in the story um well because this was
you could kind of base it like three
last of us post last of us like whatever
sure
pretty much yeah i think he got too
expensive um yeah at that point
it was like leading for his attack this
is the head but
i think naoto is another weird one where
i don't think they've ever
they they've never been able to keep a
consistent natto voice
well like just like all the time
yeah well like ga and teddy were
different in the original for right she
and teddy were different as well but
once they changed out she and teddy they
kept them
consistent and
uh it's funny like
chie you can definitely tell is
different teddy
it was actually a heart to even notice
to be honest he was really good really
close that makes sense
but
yeah naoto i think they've they've
changed out a few times
and
i think laura bailey didn't do lisa and
dancing
yeah cause she didn't she was replaced
by ashley burch i think
yes she was he did a good job
it was just it was just weird because
you're like oh this whole
story is focused on risay
[Music]
that's the thing about like
i guess it's just you know a system of
circumstance but i appreciate it with
all the persona 5 spin-offs like all the
cast members have come back for all of
them yeah yeah
i think it's just more of like
the unfortunate case of a lot of the
personal forecasts like uh blew up
specifically like laura bailey and char
baker oh yeah although it was funny
because they were all in catherine too
um they were like they were all uncapped
as well so it was like yeah like three
last of us those last of us
well i guess that's true for troy baker
um
yeah and it's also uh unfortunate that
they i mean it was just obviously his
3ds was dead but like q2 never got like
a proper dub yeah
yeah i think that was just a like
budget
that would have cost a lot to like even
if they replaced some of the voice
actors like get that many voice actors
and have it all in a 3ds cartridge and
you know post
post uh those log along what was that
game come out in the west like 2019 like
that game came out like after i started
working here and i was like even that
was like well into the switch days yeah
all right it's
probably one of the last great
3ds
yeah games think like a physical
cartridge is really hard nowadays
probably
cool i ended up finding one for like 50
bucks which wasn't bad because it was
like new for 40 but right
that's pretty like
yeah
this was like before the 3ds eshop
announced to be closed down though so i
imagine it's even more now that people
are charging it
my personal
[Music]
yeah i don't know if like the q games
would work without two screens though is
why i'm not quick to be like oh they
should afford it to switch um but yeah
if they did that'd be great because i'd
love to like see them
in hd and bring maybe like a voice cast
in for q2 and everything
yeah
maybe a little tough i don't know i
don't know how you do that
that was really good this is one fight
yeah
i like yes
how are you doing good to see you
hi brandon thanks for joining us
matt mercer it's matt mercer and p4a you
someone in the chat says so i guess they
had him for p4a not a
troy baker
yeah
so i'm curious if these lines joe we got
people in here are
matthew mercer or troy baker
or did they just swap all of uh
uh his like battle dialogue with matthew
murphy's stuff that's a great question
uh
benny ultim in the chat do you know the
answer to this question do you know if a
lot of the voice dialogue was replaced
with matt mercer for like this kind of
stuff not necessarily story mode or is
it like old troy baker stuff they're
using for maybe arena
right
because they didn't really change
or add any new like um like they kind of
took some of the characters around but i
think all that stuff
um
yeah
another persona 3 character i love
i i
love akihiko in this game this is also
the game where they introduced the whole
protein thing that uh became
kind of
way overplayed in um specifically in
queue
it becomes his whole identity
that is an interesting color choice
looks like uh
yeah he looks like in war and combat
yeah he looks like a metal psychiatrist
yeah
one that always kind of stuck out to me
because it's got like similar color
stuff to uh
to to my boy bang shishigami
um and i think that's what made me kind
of stick with it
yeah although i will say akihiko and
mitsuru's outfits in this game are
ridiculous they make fun of it in the
story but it's like why would you even
why
[Music]
um i love how i guess this is mostly the
same they just replaced a bow tie with
like a
tie
um
francisco in the chat i wonder how much
longer wait for persona 6 well right now
they're doing all those persona 25th
announcements for the rest of the year
so a lot of people have been speculating
the last one will be persona 6. yeah i
mean
if you haven't seen the website
it's
they kind of show every persona
game and there's very clearly like a
blank spot
uh and i think they said they had like
several like
big announcements
yeah like one of them was this one of
the 25th announcements was before you
imported so
you know maybe e5 fighting game i don't
know if they do two fighting games in
one long anniversary announcement but i
wonder if like if they don't do p5 8 or
arena if this is like the end of persona
5 right if we're now moving into the era
of persona 6. right
because i mean if you think about it in
terms of just like game to game like
there's five four golden royal q q2
dancing dancing there's arena but then
there's striker so they both had like a
sequel spin-off right so it's like if
you think about it in those terms
they've had like the same thing so maybe
now it's it's time to move to six if
they're ready to yeah
uh
we already talked about how the the no
one likes the one character they made
vibrance has got two spots too both
elaborated spots are great
i don't mind that they are
oh
shadow versus regular yeah oh no
there's shadow labries and then there's
shadow libraries yeah yeah there's two
oh right okay
because they added the shadow mechanic
and then yeah
weird
all right
uh what i'm saying is more libraries is
better
oh yeah
[Music]
more that that thick accent
um
have you guys played p1 and 2 and would
you like to see them make a return in
any future persona games yes they
deserve as much recognition as anyone
else
absolutely i um
never finished p1 it's kind of
it's pretty hard to go back to but i did
play uh the persona 2 duology
um
genuinely love those games
they're they are really tough to go back
to
they've got a lot of
kind of grindiness to their dungeons and
stuff like that however like their story
and characters are actually some of my
favorite in the entire franchise um
so i would i would love to see
uh those get like undo just because
i think people need to like
experience those characters
and yeah the stories go
no i completely agree like as much as
i'd love a persona three remake i think
one and two deserve a little bit more
yeah in first um
mark in the chat says they probably
won't make p5 ultimax since they put a
p4 ultimax that's my guess there's also
p5 strikers i would agree with that in a
sense we'll see if maybe them
hoarding p4 ultimax is kind of them like
gearing people up in the 5 or testing
the waters and development like i know
yeah like i know with um
i think it was wind waker hd they were
like playing around with wind waker
making breath of the wild they're like
why don't we just
rewrite the whole game in hd so
uh they did that so i wouldn't be
surprised if this was them doing that
but i also agree that like we have
enough
of p5 now similar to p4 i worry that
like if they keep going with it
might be fatigued so
i'm cool if like persona 6 is next
really
all right who we got uh on luke horses
ether all again cool
uh john luke is now toasty
the other
uh shadow libraries the authors
oh yeah they are which it's actually the
way to play them because they replaced
more closely
right yeah they don't have the uh
damn do i not get a single hit oh look
at that that happened
this is what i get for not practicing
oh it's okay it's okay
i'm just getting out having a good time
do not feel bad for kicking my ass
that's what this is for
enjoy it and then you know sweetie
i kicked their ass
i forgot there were two labrases when
you told me earlier to pick so i just
picked first
i was like whoops
[Applause]
well
a huge victory
i'll pull up that 25th anniversary site
and see what two wins what else is going
on
they recently announced like some thing
only in japan of last month of like like
a thing where you can like stay in a
hotel and see all this stuff
um and the next announcement is in april
actually so
let's see what part of it was that
those final sets which uh oh my god
i feel bad that i only got like two of
them
i didn't get any i i just didn't have
the money at the time was like i can't
i bought the uh when the royal strikers
5-1 and i have the strikers no
well i bought the digital when they came
out like gun did for streaming but um i
don't own a record player so i'm not
playing the finals
uh but yeah no they yeah they announced
like some experience that's only in
japan um so if you're in japan you can
go check it out um it starts in may i
think it's like it's called like it's
called fs like persona 25th fest or
something
um yeah they've had their their concerts
that they've done in the past uh
[Music]
oh i just i i think i mentioned this
earlier but like i haven't gotten to the
ultimate story yet i'm still playing
through the arena story so i haven't
really touched any ultimax stuff i
didn't really i haven't really touched
show at all
um
evan has no reference and if people like
show more
i think it's also just an issue of the
um
i didn't like the overall direction the
story went
[Music]
in the second one it just
it like the i thought the the setup was
so interesting and i thought the payoff
was kind of weak so
and he's kind of like tied into that in
a way
i don't know
that makes sense i mean i'm already
having issues with the not i like the
arena story i just don't like how it's
the format
yeah it's like 12 different characters
all doing like the exact same thing over
and over again
um
like i haven't played it much you know
like oh well i mean game's only enough
like two weeks but i don't play much
lately because i'm just like i need to
take a little step away from it and then
come back to it like this i can't i
can't force myself through this
that's a disservice to the story
oh dang they're selling persona 25th
anniversary
oh right yeah
like the
characters
i would get a p3 uh protagonist got both
of them on it
oh heck yeah
there's a if you go on the because atlas
west now has like their own shop i think
they also have personal 26 merchandise
yeah that's that's the one i'm looking
at i'm looking for okay i didn't know if
you're looking like the japanese
merchandise
yeah the japanese one they have a little
more stuff they do have a coaster set
that one i might get i have a couple
persona coasters that i got in japan
during the limited edition like persona
cafe that they had running um
which is pretty cool so i have like ones
from
the persona 5 animation
um and then i have ones from royal as
well
actually i have it right here this pin
that you gave me when you when you went
to
atlas in japan
maximum defeat great game loving that
you all are here and that you're all
enjoying the arena ultimax
um
all right
who's next
who's next ethereal still versus ryu
the ultimate match-up
etherol is is just uh is uh taking names
and chewing bubblegum i forgot the same
um
all right let's see i guess
versus margaret matchup of the century
the color coordination has got to be on
point it's very important
of course
all right what music we going with i'm
excited to see
so you know what
you're playing with the right people
when they they take their time to pick
the right song
these are our people
i feel like i have a feeling this is
going to be like a really good match
i'm excited for this
all right
where where we dropping boys
we are in tartarus
we haven't we've been chilling out in
tartarus for a bit i don't mind it
especially after we're all like man all
my homies hate tardis
i like tartarus as a visually i'm cool
with targets fighting
evil god elizabeth or no that's just
your retirement
daring dignified pork i like that i like
that you could pick those like goofy
taglines
i guess holding around
okay so i'm on the japanese website
so the next thing is in
his next information is in uh
april
and then there is a
let's see one two
three
four there's four more things after that
so we have five potential announcements
yeah like two of the announcements have
been like japan only things and one of
them was arena ultimate so like not all
of them we personally will benefit from
but i still put my money on the last one
being like
chairs with chains on them persona 6
um
i just won the first round
or i mean one of them could be a remake
of some kind or a port like they could
port persona 3 fps to
pc or something
i'm surprised they
for a grab
is always good
this isn't like if you like canonically
speaking because like margaret's a
velvet room attendant has all these
powers like august is an anti-shadow
weapon with like
guns in her arms so like this would be
an interesting matchup
congratulations to isis
and for all again killing it here today
in our p1 grand prix or maybe p2 grand
prix
the persona master sona master
congratulations thank you for sticking
around and playing this whole time
the shadow versions of characters make
me feel bad
i'm like i like i like i guess look at
them
and then
they're they're angry and upset and mean
and i'm like that's not hard right
i'm putting this on you guys again who
should i play us
let's see wait let's see what ethral
plays maybe i'll canonically give them a
good match
picking yukiko who would be a good
it would be a good uh ga would be a good
player
i'll go shadow chiefs we're going to
shadow yukiko
all right uh well let's pick a persona 4
stage
is that yasugami
[Music]
all right um
hope you like what you've seen so far i
don't have a lot of time to pick a song
i'm running out of time uh
crisis
i don't know we picked something i was
scrolling through
uh yeah getting started on persona is
always a fun thing because there's so
much for you to kind of
uh reach out
to
the truth shall do the truth
uh yeah i started with e5 i know john
lucy started with p4 ben did you start
did you start with
uh i started with p3
look at us we all started with a
different brazilian again
yeah
it's a it's a it's a good way to do it
you can't really go wrong
going anywhere
that's true
i just you know
to five
after all picked uh velvet room yukiko
so this makes this makes sense i like
this color match up here
uh i think this might be the first time
i'm actually playing this ga i don't
know if i mean i might have done it once
or i haven't done ga story in arena yet
i like that kick it's a good kick
trial of the dragon kick
all right i got some hits in i couldn't
i could appreciate that
okay
you got
you gotta yeah you gotta start somewhere
with it
look for some so far heck yeah what if
uh what did you
so we're hanging out playing the
fighting games
i'm glad that this game got a remaster
right now just so that they can exist
[Music]
in other places
specifically pc
you know as i say i wish the pc version
wasn't better
is it not in good shape i don't actually
man oh no
like half of the people who bought it
couldn't even play it for the first like
week
they have a beta branch up right now
that is being updated that
let's people just get into the game now
but all the resolution stuff is messed
up
uh so i can't play like you're like
they also took out the uh
the lobby mode completely which is weird
yeah i heard i well i i don't know how
true this is but i heard like the ps4
versions based on the ps3 version the
switch and pc versions based on the 360
version so the 360 version never had the
lobby i don't know true that is
but i had heard something like that's
why this version only has the lobby
um
but yeah that sucks to hear about the pc
version um i just got the ps4 version
because that's where i primarily like
have played most of my personas um
and like persona 4 gold i played on my
computer um so
but it sucks because like persona 4
golden is
uh
persona 4 golden is we're on pc so pc
players might want to play that and they
play the pc version so right they're
getting locked out of that and like pc
versions it just kind of tends to last
longer
i think like fan bases can stick around
on pc more um
they are fixing it
but it's a shame that i had a rough
launch
[Music]
i haven't heard him
do any dumb things in a while so
um yeah anyways after all good game and
now you're playing again against ben
uh doing a narakame versus june pay
eerie
nice match-up because there's no e3mc
for obvious reasons
um
ben i think i told you this i don't know
if i ever told evan about this but um
for my like senior year of college uh
that's my like one of my final projects
i actually built a persona 4 arena
arcade machine
really
yeah i was trying to find pictures of it
the other day and i
couldn't find them i think they're on
like a hard drive somewhere but
yeah i built i built an arcade machine
for the original personal arena and then
i
um
i was started to work on modifying it to
the ultimax version so i kind of changed
up the the
all the like art and stuff on the on the
cab but um i never actually finished
that project so it's still technically
just a
regular
um arena version uh but yeah that arcade
machine is still at my parents house uh
in their garage
all the way back on the east coast
what uh what did you do in college that
would have
like what did you major in i i majored
in uh creative media which is like a big
old like
like liberal arts just like ah you pick
a bunch of different things and focus on
them and do them so i i did um
film i did
kind of just like
had the opportunity to basically just do
like a bunch of like
different types of projects so i did
like some video stuff i did some
so yeah some more like you know hands-on
like
uh woodworking like art creative stuff
uh it was cool
that's cool
yeah that sounds really cool that you
just kind of got that opportunity to
like try
a bunch of stuff and you were kind of
like on a track specific thing
it also sounds like a very uh chocolate
thing to do and that's why i love it
yeah i'll tell you at the time it was
very scary of like i don't know if this
is going to lead to any sort of career
in anything at all
who knows
but it was cool because i just kind of
got to like
take the classes that i was interested
in uh and then focus on them
that's awesome thank you
i would uh if you if next time you're at
your parents place take some pictures
i'd love to see this yeah
arena cabinet i have some somewhere
i would i would love to
send them to you guys show them off
all right
good fight by the way a heck of a i
could be you
yeah that was that was very impressive
ethereal in here
just slaying you know
mastery of all the characters yes oh
yeah
are you sure there's a pass limit i'll
pass if there isn't
well i thought there was but i might be
wrong
oh whoa what oh did they choose to drop
oh yeah oh that's why you want to drop
we appreciate you being considerate of
that though
um
no p5 on pc yeah no no p5 on pc although
uh persona 5's leaving that yes plus
collection and it's also been five years
since it came out so i don't know maybe
maybe some sort of secret exclusivity
feels ending
um we'll see
there we go i i went back and i switched
oh now
is that me
versus weed wagon sun let's go
i love that name i love it
all right i'm going to keep going with
this canonical thing so whoever you go
with
i will pick you the oh you're going okay
so i have to go margaret right it's
elizabeth versus margaret
[Music]
um
some of the references for the colors
were a little bit better
because there's there's something very
obvious
yeah although i don't know if all of
them are references to something
all right i have played margaret maybe
once so let's go
um
ooh well i guess starters make sense i
wonder is there like a velvet there's
not a velvet room stage is there in this
game
no not that i can think of okay
this is a good one
oh wait i should have kept my just
regular velvet room attire
i also find it funny and i guess it
makes sense like margaret's the older
sister but elizabeth came first
all right
oh hey i found uh
i found some pictures from an old reddit
there we go heck yeah
everyone should see weed wagon sun's
amazing skills as the wonderful velvet
room attendant elizabeth no name last
name
i don't know developer attendance have a
last name i don't even
know we're actually we're actually neck
and neck here i didn't realize that i
just assumed i was losing
that we
uh
i've never noticed that the nintendo wii
yeah wow
that was intense that was a great fight
down to the wire
down to the literal wire reese says it
best
opening
man those velvet room attendants in
their books
they sure know how to read
but they don't with their those are
persona companions right
i think so yeah
i was kind of just assumed
okay
did she always say we before
maybe she's a fan of the nintendo wii
why am i losing my mind
i want to say she did
it was damn 64 hit combo it was
impressive
i like this move i keep using it i'm
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow who's gonna win this
oh you say only 69 viewers oh that's not
a nice number
um
yeah damn this is we're like we're
evenly matched here i think with our
skill levels
that was like down to the wire both ends
of the spectrum now we're gonna see
who's the ultimate winner
[Music]
well i mean
i get it like you know persona this is a
sequel to two games one of them's only
on pc one of them you can't play right
now like i i understand how hard of a
sell this is for some people um
we just genuinely like this game yeah
that's always friday that's that's
really all it is
look at how many times in my my my
twitter tweet record where i'm like damn
i sure wish persona 4 green ultimates
were available on anything other than
playstation 3.
yeah
you can look forward to a similar stream
when the jojo game comes out
oh yeah
dude i'm so excited
fantastic the fantastic match
i i really appreciate that uh because i
think we were evenly skilled there um
that was a great fight elizabeth versus
margaret going down in the history book
all right let me see if i can punch we
gotta see that we gotta see that cabinet
yeah let's see let's see if this works
here
uh
will i save that replay yes i will that
was a good one so that's that's the
replay we're saving
can you get wagons that was a great
fight
oh heck yeah
yo that's
the way you could tell me that that's
like the thing that you bought from
oh yeah that's incredibly impressive
like a proper setup and i believe you
yeah wow
that's beautiful
i love it
and then uh there's it in action
thank
you
art i basically like ripped all of the
like our asset files uh i felt like
people who like sprite ripped everything
ripped all the sprites out and then like
made all that in photoshop
oh man damn that is amazing
all right then me and you and somewhere
somewhere deep on a hard drive i have
all the persona
uh arena ultimax versions where i like
have the blue and the red
oh whoops
um who are you fighting as you're you're
laborious okay
who would be a good lavers counterpart
would it be mitsuru is like
rijo group
that makes sense to me okay i'm going to
go with missouri
it's pretty cool
well i guess it has
button wait can i not can i go back now
that i've chose oh i ran out of time i
see
i wanted to do the shadow version but i
guess i'm going with the regular that's
cool brandon brandon asks what we're
going to be playing this weekend i don't
want to be playing more of that kaito
dlc for lost judgment ooh i finished it
it's really good oh heck yeah that's
what i like to hear
that's really good
it's not that long it took me like it
took me like seven hours to get to the
whole thing oh really
it's not bad at all there's only uh four
chapters
dang
i'm gonna i'm gonna definitely slow down
and try to save her because i was
hearing people say that like oh man this
has got way more to it than i thought it
did
uh
knowing how many chapters there are
okay yeah um because there's not really
like any side content like there's no
like you can't really like there's no
like
it's kind of just like pushing you
towards the story which i guess makes
sense because if you want to decide
stuff
i want to see you know kaito play guards
or something
i want to hear kaito uh sing karaoke
yeah
i want to see kaito go on dates and
stuff well actually it doesn't make
sense given the story of this game
but uh yeah what i played so far have
been really really great i
can't wait to see more of it
uh and then after that probably
probably grind out some stuff in final
fantasy 14 since we've got a patch
coming up with a bunch of new content
they're bringing out a new ultimate
that's going to make everyone cry
because
it involves a really emotional moment in
the game
anyway i'm not going to talk about
that game
well
yeah i mean i i'm not i haven't i
honestly haven't played like any final
fantasy besides seven remake i have not
touched
although that new one seems hilarious
chaos stranger paradise yes
the chaos emerald
oh
he's
trying to find chaos he was trying to
find a chaos emerald the whole time yeah
that or uh
perfect chaos you know take over the
city
where you going the big trip
uh
anyway sonic's really good sometimes
uh yeah i'm excited for the new one uh
frontiers i think it's called
the breath of the wild killer
that's that's what we're we're calling
that's what i'm here for
oh it
okay i was like why is my chain about
pulling me forward and i realized i have
to hold forward
um
yeah
take it taken down taking down my robot
oh we're not gonna play lost judgment on
here it's just it's just a weekend plan
we uh we did actually a few months ago
when the game came out we did a stream
you can go watch the three of us um and
then yeah the dlc just came out the the
kaito files uh which stars
forget his first name but ito um
and a bunch of new characters bunch of
returning characters like higashi and
hoshino both great
like this with that giant winter coat on
your determination
yeah i guess i can see that
holy cow
i was i'm surprised by that that was a
great game then
yeah
that was really maybe i'll start mating
mature or something you're like you're
going on me and everything
i'm never going to be heavy
yeah you can't get up cause the code's
too heavy oh
[Music]
combat experience you combat robot that
was designed for combat
yikes
all right john look if we fought yet i
don't think so i think this is the first
time you and i are getting into battle
this is destiny
yeah i'll do another cannon fight i'm
enjoying this for myself okay
whoever you pick i'll pick the the one
that makes more sense to fight you you
know what no one's playing marie yet
okay who would be yes would that be
margaret again
probably
yeah okay margaret
i'll do that i'll do the actual velvet
room
uh
uh put her glasses on because it's just
an eye patch oh no i didn't get a chance
[Music]
she have a theme
[Music]
it's gonna pick for you all right
who knows who knows what i got
all right margaret versus marie question
mark question mark question mark
question mark question mark
so many questions so many questions
is it this is yes we got me right now
yeah yeah
okay i picked some weird
isn't it not a
placebo character kind of look like that
there's uh
there's one with the green hair yeah i
don't know if that's exactly what
they're going for
it's like marie's a big fan of shrek you
know you got the the brown vest and the
green
yeah
the short color
yeah
i could see marie being like a big shrek
man
you could tell me that i believe it so
yeah yeah you don't remember that part
in her social link where you introduce
her to shrek
and you watch it changes your life
every time she uses a personal ability
she says get out of my swamp you know
you know who would actually be in a
shrek would be
elizabeth would ironically be like
oh yeah
oh totally i could totally see that
boy
persona ranking on who's most likely to
be in the shrek
um
that's a great question because like
there's like the irony aspect of shrek
right and i think you got to think like
who would be into that like who would
know enough about the fairy tales it's
making fun of and also be into the irony
of it like that might be like i could
see yukiko being into that so you could
go like like laughing hysterically yeah
like futaba would be like into the memes
the shrek yeah
i don't think margaret would like track
i think she'd be like this is stupid oh
yeah absolutely yes uh uh elizabeth
would try and get her to watch all the
shrek films and margaret would like
yeah i don't think caroline and justine
would like it either they think it's
true
and then and then theodore would just be
very confused
oh yeah what about
the musical
that's another way
which is actually fantastic if you
haven't seen i have not seen it actually
i can't recommend it enough if you can
tolerate shrek you can check out the
musical
good to know
all right
oh see mark in the chat yukiko would be
in there she's literally a princess in
her castle
she would also be the worst person to
watch it with because her she'd just be
laughing nonstop
what it's raining what i've never seen
this uh that is a um
marie specific ability she has water
effects
oh yeah it changes
yeah
[Music]
an instant kill
here yeah
well it's it's like hard to pull off
right because you have to go down three
times and then do the move right like
down down down
yeah it's actually not too hard to pull
it off it's but you have to have 100 um
[Music]
i feel like i was trying it the other
day and i was like
that was a good game though that was a
really good game that was good
um i feel like i'm liking margaret a lot
now now that i've i think this looks
like kind of
[Applause]
where can i get this game you can get
this game on playstation 4 nintendo
switch and pc digital only
actually was on switch i had no idea
yeah well people just kind of stopped
talking about it because it's the one
that's not getting rollback for some
reason
rollback's only coming to ps4 and pc
it's not coming to switch which is
bizarre and also you know what can you
play what persona games can you play on
switch strikers in this like yeah two
sequels to games although i'll say i
remember i picked up um
uh crosstag battle on switch and that
was a genuinely very good version of
that game that i had a lot of fun
playing on switch so
it's good to know
um but yeah i think the switch version
was kind of like because like yeah the
ps4 version had the lobby and then pc
will also get rollback so switch was
kind of like
considered the inferior version of the
game yeah
um
which is unfortunate but uh
yeah it also sucks that it's digital
only which i guess i understand like
it's a 30
game they're not like you know probably
really expensive to make physical copies
right um
but yeah it's digital only on uh psn
shop two physical copies of the original
version both on xbox and ps3
there you go you're all set i'm all set
um it just sucks because like for this
because it has all the dlc and
everything so it would be cool there's a
physical version of preserve on that dlc
that's what i like about like definitive
versions of games where it's like all
that dlc now gets preserved in a
physical format which is like
how i weirdly feel with mario kart 8
deluxe was like i was glad all the dlc
from the base game is on the cartridge
but now they're adding more dlc
well
that's a whole difference okay they'll
release a new
yeah the switch to pro xl new
mario kart 8 deluxe deluxe
i do like those tracks a lot though
they're very good oh yeah oh they're
great the music is fantastic
dango
ethylene back with a vengeance yeah
um
and playing as margaret who i like a lot
now see margaret yeah
sam's undertale
wait just missing the eye glove
yeah i guess you could say the card
through that blue glove
that are our
parrot card arcana
it's funny like just the drastic
difference with persona 4 like you know
they have the card to summon their
persona but like persona 3 has the
evoker like that's the god
what a stark difference there because at
least with persona 5 it's like when they
first rip their mask off like their face
are bleeding but like
the difference between three and four
tonally in some ways just from like on a
surface level is very fascinating to me
especially because those two games came
out like two years apart
i remember all the
the the many
forums
the
the arguments back and forth about how
personal four was a baby game for babies
because it was too poppy and colorful
2 a.m is that tomorrow in those forums
peter brown would have been there being
like they're both stuck in the russian
tennessee's better
uh mark thank you so much for tuning in
uh and for talking persona with us i
hope you have a good night
uh we got more people in here oh that's
cool yeah we're probably gonna go for
another i'd say 10 minutes go to 11 30.
now we'll call it there
i still do got things to take care of
today
um all right let's see who the match-up
is
elizabeth is another versus margaret
yes it is another elizabeth versus
margaret match
the velvet room attendants
fighting for their game
it's a it's a good fight and you love to
see it i do love see i just wish there
was a velvet room level i've said that
like 30 times now
we've seen so many elizabeth margaret or
velvet room attended match-ups
that's for persona 5
yeah it's true we need well
so you only you know well you could play
i wonder if they used the spoiler
version of the velvet attendant and p5
if it was like a sequel
oh yeah i didn't think about that
maybe
they'd probably use both yeah
both situations i wonder what it'd be
like for them to fight each other
yeah
my
how long has
[Music]
a little competition here
they're like finally i've been in this
lobby for so long
and kicking these game journalists
assess
[Music]
all right let's see
who will win oh that's where all
etherall is coming back
well he was killed
i don't want to root for etherol because
we've been here but
oh yep okay after all still on top but
there's still another round
i wish i could like
that's a lot to wrap your mind around
too with the whole baseball triangle
diamond thing it's true you've got to
play a game of baseball with the person
you're fighting yeah i still don't
understand how that works
[Music]
yeah yeah that summer right
yeah
oh man that was so close that was very
very close but uh etherall stays on top
as the ultimate game spot for sona for
arena ultimax winner
congrats
as always
i like that the comment they made is
specific to the fact that there's two of
them fighting like that
all right who's up next
assuming ethereal versus john luke all
right
battle of who's it gonna be
okay
interesting
we interact in p4 i think right like
marie's social links yeah yeah i think
they all they met her
i like the clothing store
[Music]
i want to say and then yeah like there's
there's a couple events where the whole
the group all shows up
right okay cool
so this isn't out of the realm of
possibility
i love that that's a great intro
oh yeah
i like
i can appreciate marie but i think
through most of the game i was like i'm
not the biggest fan
uh just not knowing anything about the
mode and the context from the fighting
game did you seem kind of neat
oh yeah um i think like
i also might be spoiled because like if
we're comparing like new character added
like i think kasumi is a much better
edition
to like their base game yeah i mean it's
uh
it'd almost be disappointing if she
wasn't just in the sense that like you
know the lessons they learned from marie
like how to integrate a character
properly in this game
yeah
that's true
oh boxed in
the corner is a dangerous place
one of the characters over to the fourth
wall break like wait why are we only
fighting on a
horizontal line
[Music]
yeah
all right i think we got room for one or
two more
sounds good
you're wearing green again
well that's okay
it looks really good on you after all
oh
i like it i like that uh yukiko and chia
christmas colors
is that intentional
i have no idea
all right who's that me versus new
person as you were destroyer 28
okay so i think we'll do that and then
then you'll get one more and i think
we'll call it there
all right all right i am ready
whenever you play as azure i will play
your canonical partner
good fights
uh would like yukari feel threatened as
like another actress person
or maybe like you
i feel like maybe maybe i think teddy's
hurt her uh opposite because okay he's
always hitting on her and she always is
pissed at him
fair enough i well i ran out of time so
i went with teddy
[Music]
um i've never i don't know if i've
played teddy so this week uh let's just
do random select spend more time with
what secret base i like that song uh
where's um
xxo for you is that a reset song
maybe i also can't really see it on the
okay that's it
oh you can oh you can't see it it was
weird it like froze there it was just
stuck inside
okay i didn't know what that seemed like
a recent thing
uh the opi fighter bob jones is the one
that's in your heart
the one that you like most
[Music]
you can turn on boss versions of the
characters which are just stupid
overpowered versions of all of them
it's real it's real stupid uh
some characters are just
too much
i don't like i did not
i did not mean to pick shadow teddy i
think that was just i didn't have time
to change it
i don't know what shadow teddy does
uh be creepy
yeah
if he wasn't already creepy enough
you have a baseball bat too
i don't know
i mean my first time ever playing this
game was when the remaster came out i
never played the original i'm a late
persona fan i came in with five
oh my goodness
i mean teddy deserves this so i don't
feel bad
that's that's the best thing about
picking them
yeah that's true i don't mind this i
don't mind reset just beating the ever
loving [ __ ] out of teddy
[Music]
run
i just realized they have uh the
japanese place
oh yeah
isn't that the same voice as haruka in
yakuza yes
oh really
i got disconnected oh no no
i like teddy getting crap oh was i the
one that was disconnected
i guess so
i guess so he just said disconnect here
let me uh
i guess you get to destroy me uh azure
let's let's do it
well we'll call it here on uh on this
last one with ben
that's fine
who knows sorry everyone
oh i can't spectate cause i just reached
okay i'll watch it i'll watch it through
the stream
i like that color scheme for june pain
i mean too it's the one that i always
kind of settled on
after all all right good games all after
all thank you so much for being here
playing with us a lot of fun showing us
the moves
um
this person is azure destroyer your name
makes sense
we're a good reset player
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
electrocuted like crazy
he's not demand i guess
oh
i am i mean that's some good that's some
good garden
i feel like i'm not good at the timing
on like the garden so oh my god i keep
hitting it
i keep hitting it
like that uh bass that like bass like
slide into the
i'm insane it's one of my favorite like
stupid music
oh i went for it again
oh man
i didn't
know that bruce they could do after that
stuff that's really though
good game good game
good games all around well yeah thank
you everyone for joining us
yeah that's gonna do it here for this
uh casual friday live stream where we're
just playing persona and having a good
time we appreciate
all of you
just hanging out with us uh hopefully
you had a good time just uh
you know chat about persona chatting
about
uh
fighting games chat about whatever um
thank you evan for joining us
thanks for having me yeah
yeah
i uh
i love i love doing these casual friday
streams with you guys they're fun a lot
of fun so yeah and we got to play some
persona and beat the [ __ ] out of each
other
uh
brandon have a good weekend yourself in
the chat karaoke to death i guess that's
true
it's a good way to go
love it all right guys we'll catch y'all
later have a good weekend everyone
you